hello everyone
uh welcome to today's session we will be
starting
this program shortly thank you for
joining us today
it's great to have you all here
i need
hello everyone so we will be starting in
about 15 more minutes thank you for
joining today and for your patience
we will record the session again and
post it in
our youtube channel if you're interested
to re-watch
today's session and during the session
please keep your microphones muted
and your video turned off if you have
any questions the
chat box will be open and our team
members will be
answering any questions that you have so
thank you again
hello everyone it's great to see
everybody here
so we will be starting in just about a
few more minutes
thank you for joining us again
welcome to this webinar where we will
speak about
our new product that we have been
working on
the omics logic code playground
code playground is the place to learn
and practice bioinformatics coding by
following
interactive tutorials and completing
challenges
in r and python these courses and
exercises will help you
understand how to analyze and visualize
omics data to extract meaningful
insights
from large biological data sets we hope
that you too will use this resource to
learn
practice and achieve bioinformatics
greatness
with concise exercises and interesting
challenges
right in the comfort of your browser
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our growing community
before we begin
let me introduce what omits logic is and
how the training resources we will
discuss
today have been developed and are used
in the omics logic training programs
and for research support in academic
institutions
around the world i'm honored to have
been working with a team that
collectively have
amazing experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background
with expertise in oncology immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation has a
long-standing recognition for his
generous support
of many international projects and
research activities
one of these projects is the
establishment of the
tubber bioinformatics research center
which has been
at the core of what we do dr leonid
brotzky is the director of the turbo
bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics
and biostatistics he has numerous
publications on bioinformatics and over
the course
of his career has developed multiple
novel
algorithmic approaches to biomedical
data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical research
and development
agriculture and basic research what we
will discuss today
is a result of hard work by some of the
people
mentioned here julia pinoff is an expert
bioinformatician
and helped prepare many of the materials
we will use
avi titivski is a computer scientist and
leads the development of the t-band info
platform
that we use in our omics logic programs
dr
mohit mazumdar is in charge of business
development and a project
mentor joshua maintains the
educational portal and of course there
are many more that i simply do not have
the time to mention today
omics logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between
pine biotech innovative big data
analytics company based in the us and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic
programs have been thoroughly tested
around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as faculty
interested in data science and
biomedical research
now i would want to invite elia brodsky
the ceo
and co-founder of pine biotech to talk
more about this platform with you
over to you elia thank you very much
and i'm happy to see many of you that
we've
gotten to know in the past programs and
in different types of situations so what
i'll do today
is briefly introduce you to this
new and exciting project for us which
was the development of the code
omixlogic playground
so as beeps mentioned my name is elia
brodsky for those of you that are
joining for the first time i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pi biotech
and i want to tell you a little bit
about what pine biotech is seeking to
achieve
our vision is to enhance human health
and well-being
by enabling biological discovery with
relevant data
solutions and expert support and so
we've been working
for the past couple of years on
developing a number of
resources that will allow biologists to
easily manage
process analyze and visualize their data
so as a result as you know we have
developed
a number of educational resources that
include
our t-biome for platform that was
designed and developed at the tauber
bioinformatics research center
and our team has been working on
applying some of the methods
in that platform to allow a seamless
transition from
learning about bioinformatics to
specializing in different bioinformatics
domains and applications to then
translating that
knowledge and those skills to
independent projects
that could be supported by our team
and so as we looked at the field that
we're in
we realized that we discovered
that these tools are basically
creating a solution for the gap
in research and discovery and an
important part of that
solution is coding so we realize that as
students become proficient in the logic
of bioinformatics and are able to apply
different methods for processing big
data they need to
be more empowered with downstream
analysis tools that include a typical
collection
of different libraries and code blocks
in r and python
and so then we started working on
expanding that
idea into a product into a solution that
i think
fits in very nicely with the rest of the
tools that we have
so as a result working with our team
we've designed and developed
this onyx logic code playground
the playground allows a user to
learn about different types of
challenges
understand the code approach and then
actually
practice that code within the browser
and so the way that we kind of thought
about this is that we want to allow
people to understand what are some of
the challenges
learn the different pieces of code and
the syntax
to be able to start off with a template
that they can modify including the
different
outputs and the settings and then learn
to apply that
to a data set of their own and by
incorporating this into the other
solutions that we already have
into the tbi info platform and into the
educational portal
we are able to really fill in that gap
that allows biologists and people with a
minimal
technical background to really develop
coding skills
as they work on projects of their own
and so
as we have done with the t-biome
platform
our objective over the course of the
next several months
is to really supplement the areas of
analysis for genomic
transcriptomic epigenomic metagenomic
and proteomic data
with these tools and methods that we
will provide tutorials on
in different languages like r and python
so today i wanted to start off with a
brief demonstration
of how it actually works
so for all of those that are new to the
omixlogic
playground i want to ask you to go to
code omixlogic.com and website if you
could please
paste that in the chat
so if you could go to this website
the registration is free so if you have
not registered
already you can just go ahead and
register for free
and you will see that in each category
of courses we have some
free resources that you can leverage
right away
so please let me know once you've been
able to reach this page and i'll
continue from there
once you create your account and you log
in you will have access
to different courses and so we wanted to
start with this set of courses
that allows anyone to get started with
coding in r
python an introduction to data science
and then several examples applied to
genomic data
meta genomic data and transcriptomic
data
our goal is to add new lessons and
courses
every week to this platform so we hope
that this is just a resource
that we are getting started with and
today i will also
show you how easy it is to add new
lessons and tutorials
so for those of you that are interested
in working with us
on expanding this resource we are happy
to
connect with you and discuss what are
the opportunities to actually
uh expand this resource and utilize in
different domains
so right now we are applying this to the
domain that we're in and the onyx logic
training and i'll talk a little bit more
about how we do this in the onyx logic
programs
and if you have an idea for a tutorial
in r or
python i will show you how easy it is to
add a new resource
onto this platform and make it available
online
so as you join i want to demonstrate one
of the examples it's not going to take a
very long time
but we can actually try to do this
together so that you really get a sense
of what
can be done in a very short period of
time
and how the courses expand your
understanding of bioinformatics in
application to different types of data
sets
and an in-depth look at the different
types of
challenges that are solved with these
analyses so let's go to introduction to
data science in
r you can see here a description
of the overall course this introduction
to data science
in r is a part of our data science omics
logic training program
but it can also be standalone
should we use this to create an account
for code playground
uh yes again for those of you that
already have a an account
on the educational portal you can
actually use the same
email address and i will show you how
the two are connected so they are
interconnected as you know we use this
point system
to track activity and all of those are
integrated
and you will notice that within each
course
there are going to be several lessons
that are free
and several lessons that are called
premium now this premium option
comes at a minimal price the
subscription
is ten dollars a month and as i
mentioned
these types of tutorials will expand as
we move forward
every week our plan is to add new
material to this site
so once you're in this course let's open
up
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis and visualization
just so that i have a sense of how many
of you are with me
and adapt my pace accordingly could you
let me know
if you've reached this course so i know
how many of you are following along
all right excellent thank you very much
okay so principal component analysis
allows us to study
continuous data for example gene
expression data
to understand how the gene expression
characterizes samples placing them
into a single multi-dimensional space
and reducing the dimensionality so that
we can understand
differences between samples or groups of
samples
in a scatter plot in a visual output
so here we describe the input data you
can see the input data is a set of
samples characterized by 15 genes
with their gene expression values listed
right here in the cells
a little bit about this data set this
data set comes from a cancer study
that is focused on identifying different
subtypes of cancer so let's take a look
at
how we can apply principle component
analysis
in r so that we understand the syntax
the analysis approach and what are some
of the different options that you can
modify and use
to improve the basic visualization so as
you can read right here
the first thing that we have to do is
load some
libraries as anyone who's used r before
you know that one of the major
challenges is setting up your
environment
and so that's the first thing that we
want to eliminate by
offering this platform instead of
dealing with everyone installing the
different
packages and resolving dependencies and
maybe
not having the right version to be able
to run something
we want to just jump into the code and
understand what it does
so as you read through this we will
refer to the specific
libraries and then we will explain how
the data is loaded
in and transformed so that it is ready
for the analysis now what's amazing
about our
and many of the packages in python is
that the actual analysis could be done
in a couple of lines of code so it's
really easy to learn and get started
without being overwhelmed with how to
actually structure your analysis
so what we do here is use a basic
analysis with principal component which
is achieved by
doing pr comp to the transpose data
table
that we loaded in and a very simple
output is just creating a scatter plot
of principal components that looks
already somewhat informative
now as we go through the rest of the
code you will see how we can
improve the output adding colors
adding the loadings for the different
genes that we have or the features
and eventually plotting this in 3d
so let's take a look at how to do this
importantly we don't want to just
provide you with an opportunity to
rewrite the code copy and paste and then
see the result we also want to
understand what this analysis
does along the way so let's take a look
here
you have an editable piece of code that
you can try running
right away so if you click on run
the code will run in the cloud and
produce
an output
okay so you can see that the output is
being produced those
images are going to load and let's just
take a look at what we did here
so we have a file this file is stored on
github and then we can read the table
convert it to a matrix transpose the
matrix
and then run our principal component
after we run the principal component you
see that we can plot it
or we can even print out what is inside
of this result because r is an object
oriented language
we can actually print it so we can add
here print
pca so let's run it again
and we see what is in the object so in
the object we have
all of our genes and we have some
principal component
analysis results so you can see here pc
1 2 3 etc so what we do is we actually
take this analysis and we can visualize
it using
the standard scatter plot option which
is
shown right here plot pca x
and y or we can use the
gg fortify package which allows us to
create a gta plot
object that is easy to work with to
improve the visualization
and add all kinds of additional
information onto this single plot
so what's important here is that we've
explained the code
and explain the problem and then we also
demonstrate how you actually run it
right within the browser being able to
modify
different aspects of this code to be
able to improve the visualization
or even change the file that you're
working with so change the data set
very easily so here we explain
some additional information about this
code
including an insight into how to add
some more information for example to
output
a textual result which will be
a file so if you look at this
new area you can try writing this code
and adding this part of the script right
here
if i run this as it is so if a student
wants to just
run whatever and complete all of the
steps without thinking about the problem
they won't be able to so you can see
that i'm getting an error and i can see
what the error is
and the air as obviously seen as seen
right here
is that the code is incomplete and i
even have
the red parentheses here that show me
that it's incomplete
so what do i have to do now the student
or the participant
who's trying to learn r really needs to
go back and see
what am i trying to do and how can i do
it on my own
so actually this part is very new so
this is going to be very simple to solve
let's solve it together
so here we see what the code does we
load the library
we have the input file already we define
the data and we even have the sample
names already
and pca is also already
mentioned here but what we have here is
printing the length of pca result
object so how do we print the length of
this object
we simply take this and place it inside
the parentheses so
if i want to print the full object
i just do pca result if i want to know
the length of this object
i have to put it within the parenthesis
and
here it says add here the script to
print the results table
now here i have how this table would be
printed so i can
for now just copy and paste it right
here
let's clear the console and
run it again
okay and here we discovered uh there's
another
problem so let's see what the issue is
okay right here so make the plot from
the previous step
so we also need to make the plot so how
did we make the plot previously
we did auto plot that for
the pca right so we can just copy that
right here
let's place it here again let's clear
the console
excellent so our code is successful and
the answer is correct
so for each time that we run this code
you're actually rewarded with points
encouraging you to complete and build up
your profile
as you master these basic skills now we
learned
how to load data how to transform data
how to analyze data
and also how to explore different types
of outputs
including visual and textual so if we
look at this text
we can now see this is a table that
shows us the position of the samples in
the principal
component space but it's not so easy to
understand
what does that actually mean so here we
have the example of that
output what are these principal
components
why are we getting a 2d scatter plot
instead of a
3d scatter plot so how do we actually
understand
what this information can provide us
with if you plot
the pca object with a bar plot
you will also get an understanding of
how this
pca result characterizes the full data
set and we can see here that the
principal component one
is the most informative component so it
captures the most variability between
different samples but as those
pcs continue to add on and all together
form a hundred percent
we can kind of see the threshold after
pc5
they're not informative of course to get
a scatter plot
we cannot visualize all of the data
in all of the components the maximum we
can do is three
so if we visualize that in 3d
we will actually see the relationship
between the components
and what they mean and how twisting and
combining different principal components
together
can help us visualize the differences
between the samples
so let's learn about how to do this in
the next step
by going beyond the basics
so if you open the next step you will
see that we will start
improving on this basic visualization
and try to apply
clustering in this multi-dimensional
space
to understand what new information we
can get
out of this analysis so here you can see
that we have a basic way to perform pcea
which is pr
comp and create an object
we can change the way that we analyze
instead of pierre comp
using k means and for k means
we all know that we need the number for
the k so the number of expected class
classes or the clusters that we expect
here
now if we print this we will see that an
additional level
of information is added to our
output however the output
looks like com the cluster
cluster number one combines normal-like
and
basal samples so these are two different
subtypes of cancer
but they are combined into a single
cluster
and for example here we have an overlap
between luminal
and basal and normal-like and here we
also have
two different clusters for the luminal
so something doesn't seem
right if we use
a different method so instead of k-means
there's an additional message
there are additional methods called
clara feni or pam
which stands for clustering large
applications clustering
or for pam it's partitioning around
midioids
and we can try how these different
additional types of clustering
can help us understand what is in our
data
so if we change from that function
to other methods of clustering we will
get a different result so let's
try to evaluate what we are getting in
this output
it looks like with this output
normal-like
and basal are almost perfectly separated
except for a small overlap right here
with basal
being in the normal like but basal from
luminal and from cloud and low
are actually separated quite well we can
also see
that principal component has a
percentage and pc1 indeed
explains 55 percent of the variance as
opposed to pc2
only 18.34 so let's see
if we understood how to write this code
first of all we have the library already
loaded
can i just run this
unfortunately there's no input file
either so now i have to add
more of the code so in this
ability to learn about the code go
through the problem statements
and start developing coding skills what
we do
is we go through these simple
explanations
show how easy it is to modify the
settings and then put a challenge in
front of you
using this challenge students are going
to be motivated because they understand
how easy it is
but at the same time they really have to
understand that they're able to do this
independently
each time that a student completes a
code block
they're rewarded with points and those
points are being reported
under their profile anyone that wants to
then
take this code over to them so let's say
you wrote an elaborate code
and you made this code look exactly like
you want this and you want to save it
for future reference
how do you actually get the code well
it's very easy
at the bottom of each one of your code
blocks you have this copy
button and it copies to the clipboard
and now you can just open this
in your rstudio and run it from there
so what this does is it allows
anyone to try to work through the
problem in the browser
helping understand what is the correct
answer
what are the mistakes and running it
right within the browser to not have to
deal with any installation
or any kind of technical uh setting that
they have
on their computer after they complete
this
and you can see that this is the
challenge so after they complete the
challenge
they get an additional number of points
for completing the whole lesson
the progress is being tracked so if i go
back to my courses
you can see that for those courses that
i have started
this is being tracked and importantly
this is going to be in the achievements
right here so maybe some of you
are recognizing some of your names
because
you are you are completing some of the
code blocks
and you're trying to do some of this
analysis together with me
so all of this is being tracked and what
we hope to do
by offering you a short survey
at the end of each course is to
understand
how the participants learn
and are able to apply different methods
to different types of
data sets and eventually start offering
a recommendation so really to make it
personalized
and offer the suggestion for what you
should do next
based on your objectives now importantly
all of this information is linked in
with your account
that account is linked also to our main
educational portal so if i go here to
the educational portal
for those of you that already have an
account i can also see that you're
completing those steps and i know what
we are working on so all of these people
are working on principal component
analysis
all of this information is stored under
your profile
combined with the theoretical courses
that you take
on the educational portal as well as the
pipelines that you run
on the server that t-bio info platform
not only that the tbi info platform is
also connected
by offering short scripts for different
types of methods
that you can directly put into the code
onyx logic playground
to try and rewrite the scripts that the
platform use
uses as you do different types of
analyses
for example if i go to my pipelines
i know that recently i ran a pca
on the platform inside the outputs
there is a result file but i can also
get an r script
if i was using not the regular pca but
the pcar library
so from a perspective of an educator
i can build the experience to go from
very simple and theoretical to practical
in the sense of a user of bioinformatics
to a person who's familiar with what
stands behind each button
and how they can develop independent
skills to continue and develop
their bioinformatics capacity
i hope that this was an informative
demonstration again we have options
for both r and python and if you have
any
questions please put them in the chat so
i'll be happy to respond to them right
now
before i move on to how this looks from
someone who wants to contribute
to this platform and develop tutorials
in python and
r using the code omix logic
playground
okay so not everyone at once i hope and
keep your
questions uh if you have any other
questions you're welcome to email us
to marketing at pine.bio we'll be happy
to continue to speak with you about it
so the courses that we've developed so
far cover
a basic introduction to bioinformatics
developing a sense of data science
and some basic courses in genomics
metagenomics and transcriptomics
okay so there's a question if i want to
load
an existing file on my desktop to the
platform how am i going to do that
so i'm actually going to show you in a
second what the backend looks like
and explain how you can create your own
tutorial
right here on the platform storing your
data and images
within the course so here i have
um and by the way for
if you mean as a user as a student how
do you load an existing file on your
desktop to the platform
i can show you that in python in just a
second
so the objective of the courses that we
have
is to go from the very beginning by
loading files
to then knowing how to visualize
the data and doing summary statistics
analyzing the data for
variants and other types of statistical
characterization doing exploratory
analysis and eventually being familiar
with the different types of challenges
addressed in genomics metagenomics
transcriptomics
and other type of data as you know these
courses
are project driven so we made it so that
people can try to apply the same methods
to their own data without having to
rework everything but really
understanding the logic
and being able to simply replace the
files
with whatever they are interested to use
now i showed you today how it looks in
python r and i want to show you in a
couple of minutes of what it looks like
in python as well
so let's go back and load
a different course so i'm just going to
go back to the courses page and we'll go
to getting started with bioinformatics
in python
and i'm going to load this course called
reading dna using python
so this is a part of their introduction
to bioinformatics course and it's fairly
simple
and it's going to be quick i think for
you to understand of what it does
at the basic level and then i'll show
you a little bit more advanced
course that you can load files from your
computer as well
okay so once i'm here you can see that
the explanation
goes into the actual code of dna
so we have to deal here with sequences
so this is
uh you know the type of analysis that
you would want to do
and you would want to maybe align
sequences and compare their length
and what you read here in the beginning
is how
the code actually works what it does
and at the end you've learned the code
that will create a program to analyze
dna so then you can see
how here we have a simple
a simple code to analyze
a certain sequence so for example try to
print the length of a dna sequence
10 bases in length to complete this task
so following the instructions right here
if i have a sequence
i can measure how long is that sequence
right so here
if i have my first piece of code
i can paste it right here and let's try
to run it and i have success running
code and the answer is
correct now you can also see that i can
drop a file right here so i can
literally take
any file from my computer and just drop
it right here
for the for this browser-based analysis
to recognize that i have a
file stored in the browser in the
browser cache
and i recommend that you go through some
of the other
tutorials that we have to see how you
can use that
option to try to analyze different types
of data
producing visualization statistical
analysis
and even training and evaluating machine
learning models
for those that want to use this in r
it's not exactly as simple by just
dragging and dropping the file here
you do have to upload your excel file to
some kind of a cloud system and so for
those of you that are just users
it's easy to leverage github or
maybe google drive to try and do that
but if you
are a developer and maybe a faculty
member and you would like to develop
additional resources for your students
to learn
coding in python and r i want to show
you how easy it is to create such
tutorials
that you can publish on the platform
and by the way if you are interested go
ahead and reach out to us
and we'll be happy to set you up with an
account so you can try this on your own
so you can see here the back end of this
platform
it looks exactly the same i see all of
the courses that i created
or the courses that other people have
created so these are my courses
and i can add a course so
when i add the course i need to add
description maybe an
image something like that and i already
have it set it up
i have it set up right here for this
test course
it's not published and not released so
no one can really see what i'm doing
let's go in this course here i added a
couple of lessons
and a test lesson that we can try to
modify
just so that you can see how easy it is
to do this
so in the back end i have a few options
i can
make this into an r code or a python
code
so you can determine what it's going to
be
here i can choose a file if i need to
a description and save and i can make
this a free
or a paid course and here i can add
steps so if i have multiple steps for
example in the beginning
i would like to maybe just explain what
this is going to be about
once the people understand what this is
about
i want to reward them so i want to give
them some achievement
points right here and then i can add
either a text block
for example this is a test course
so i can actually write this here and i
can modify the way it looks
or i can even add here just directly by
copying and
pasting from a course that i already
have for example if i have a course here
on phylogenetic analysis i can just
take all of this text including the
images just copy it
and paste it over to see it pop up
exactly the way it was so it's really
simple to go from
existing drafts that you might have to a
course that is going to become
interactive how do i actually add that
interactive portion here
i can add videos videos
images code so if i want to write
some syntax so library ape
for example right and i can also
add different types of
code blocks so for example if i created
the second step
try this out and i'll say
code tried and then here
i'll give it 200 points for example
and i want to add a code block so here
in this code block
i can just take this code that i already
have written out right here
write it in here and
test it on my computer to know what is
the expected
answer so i just place the answer that
i expect to get from this analysis
and give it a number of completion
points to know
how to evaluate the result
so as i go through this process i can
create a step-by-step tutorial
that introduces the code block or maybe
even the specific data set that i want
to explain the challenge of that data
set
then help by understanding the syntax
and trying to run that syntax on your
own
and maybe creating a challenge with a
specific
outcome that could be the exact same
output
that i'm getting in my r studio or
python
developer environment on my computer
so it's really simple to add this to the
repository to the library of different
resources
for those of you that are faculty and
are interested in contributing
please do reach out to us so we can show
you how to create an account
as a faculty or as a student
the courses that we mentioned again if
we
go through some of the courses that we
have right here
are going to be expanding every week we
hope to add some new resources
and in fact the course that i was just
showing you right now
is added right here to compare dna
sequences using phylogenetic analysis so
we have
a full description of the ape library
where you can build phylogenetic trees
and analyze similarities between
sequences
and we will continue to expand this to
other areas as well
now before we complete the session
i also understand that there is a big
demand
for those of you that might be
interested in something like this
but don't know how to get started so let
me briefly introduce
how we provide hands-on training
for this kind of coding bioinformatics
linking together the different elements
the theoretical
the practical and the skill based like
coding
into different types of programs
for those participants that are
interested in learning
and developing a project of their own
we have a program for advanced
users and for those that are just
getting started
we have very introductory programs that
require
minimal technical background and we'll
introduce them to the
different ranges of applications of
bioinformatics so
a number of different bioinformatics
projects
for example right now we are running a
program called
introduction to bioinformatics this
program is designed
to provide the very basics without
any technical capability illustrating
how the different
processing analysis visualization and
interpretation methods
can help you understand the application
of bioinformatics to cancer biology
agriculture neurodegenerative diseases
and
infectious diseases so in this program
we have six different sessions
that are interactive so we meet twice a
week
we discuss different theoretical aspects
that are supplemented by
independent activities that they can
complete on the educational portal
on the server big data analysis platform
and on the code playground now the code
playground is optional for the
introduction
introductory course but it is something
that we go in much deeper as we continue
with the data science program so the
data science program
is actually designed with a much greater
focus
on the application of different types of
analysis methods to understand
different types of omics data understand
what happens
behind the scenes of each one of the
buttons
and also is an excellent introduction
into the domain
of machine learning for data mining
and for predictive analysis so we put an
emphasis
on such things as different methods of
clustering
application to different types of data
sets and
classification with different models
model evaluation
and eventually a number of projects that
you can develop
so that you are independent in what you
do
okay so the question there is is the
data science program part of the premium
code package or is there another fee
these interactive programs are comprised
of different aspects of these elements
that we presented today so beeps
thank you for pasting that link i will
just briefly show you
how you can learn about the pricing of
the different elements so if we go to
the data science program
let's move this out of the way
data science
the data science program includes
access to programs
to courses sorry to the code playground
interactive sessions and also
independent projects that you can
develop
with our tutorials you have also have
some advanced
options as well if you want to get
mentor support or if you have a project
a research project in mind
you can actually add on educational
cloud pipelines so you can run
pipelines on our big data server because
that's a major limitation for those that
want to
work with big data sets from cancer
biology
and others that really gigabytes and
terabytes of storage are needed to be
able to process those
so there are a number of different
options for this
these programs start and end at a
certain time so the data science the
introduction to bioinformatics
already started this week if any one of
you wants to join we only did
introductory sessions up until now so
the registration is still open until the
end of this week
but we will continue to repeat these
programs
every year so the programs are built
around a six-month cycle
and we also offer a research internship
and the research internship is really
designed for those that
want a more flexible schedule and they
really prefer to work on independent
projects
instead of following a specific
curriculum so
if we are just following
the existing curricula that we have with
dates with
set up times and topics that are run
you join a training program if you want
a flexible schedule
and you want to work on an independent
project we actually have
a number of students that are working on
their own research projects and we have
a number of examples of what
those projects look like if you would
like to know
and those are also available
as a part of a regular interaction with
a mentor
and you can actually find
this fellowship information we call it a
research fellowship
right here on this link okay just a
couple of questions let me address
those okay so
if a course has a star that means it's a
premium course
if you have a subscription that's a
basic subscription i'll
pass it on to mojit here in just a
couple of minutes to talk about the
basic subscription
we offer a very basic beginner
subscription
for code omixlogic.com or for the
educational portal
that includes everything you need to do
asynchronously
at just dollars a month uh so
you could really do this um at any time
and uh yes so most of what we talked
about
can be done in the cloud and that's what
it's built around but if you want to do
it locally you can obviously do that as
well you just don't get the points
that we keep tracking in our system
okay so let me pass it on to mohit
mazumdar
who will explain how the basic
membership works
and what types of resources are included
in the basic membership
for those of you that are interested in
the asynchronous options
thank you
okay uh hello everyone i am with
mazumdar and i am one of the global
representatives of find biotech
and in this role i'm helping students
and researchers
to learn about big data in biology today
i want to take you through our online
courses that are now
available for everyone to take under
bundled under the basic subscription
so if you want to learn about
transcriptomic data analysis here is a
complete guide of rna-seq analysis
transcriptomics one uh is an
introduction to next generation
sequencing to study the rna
express expression data uh
transcriptomics two is a course about
uh gene expression analysis and focuses
on studying variations
uh in expression between conditions so
you will learn about
factor regression analysis and t test
and learn about the statistical
statistics applied for this big data
transcriptomics 3 is a course dedicated
to analysis
advanced analysis methods such as
machine learning algorithms
that allows us to find meaningful
patterns in big data sets
especially complex patterns that are
typical in these
rna-seq experiments and transcriptomics
4
is a review of single cell rna data
analysis
and a study of time course data for
thousands of single cell samples so if
you're interested in
transatomic data analysis i would
recommend you to
check this course series and if you're
interested in genomics if you're
interested in learning about dna
and changes that happens to the genetic
code the
genomic series of course explains how
next generation sequencing can be used
to study genome-wide
genetic variation that results in
phenotypic changes
so the introduction to genomic is an
introductory course introductory and a
free course
and and genomic one covers practical
application of genomics to research and
medicine
so you will have pipelines that you can
build
in these courses so that gives you a
hands-on experience so genomic two
focuses on the analysis of a single
nucleotide variation snvs and
genome-wide association studies
guards and if you are interested
in diving into the world of microbiome
then
please review this three course series
about metagenomics
so introduction to metagenomics is again
a free course and it will familiarize
you with uh the ways microbiome
influence their hosts
and also you will learn how you can
study this unique community using
the ng ngs technology so
metagenomics one however focuses on the
impact of bacterial diversity
on human health so you will learn about
multiple types of sequencing methods
such as
16s rna and dna and then practical
analysis of 6
16s sequencing data using the tibia info
platform
so in metagenomics 2 you will learn
about
you will learn to compare microbial
composition in different conditions
and then learn about 16 s amplicon
sequencing
and that also covers uh data 2 analysis
pipelines
so for advanced advanced research
and the fourth type of data type
the fourth data type is epigenome and if
you're interested to get an introduction
to mechanisms of this
non-coding gene expression regulation
then i would recommend this epigenetic
series
and where you will learn about the
regulation of gene expression
with regulatory rnas dna methylation its
mechanisms essays
to find it and study it and ways to
analyze this data
so the data that is associated with this
assays such as bisulfite sequencing
keystone modifications in epigenomes and
also uh
chipset uh chipset data analysis
and uh last uh not
so many methods in bioinformatics as you
know requires
this application so uh in-depth
understanding of machine learning
algorithms and tools
so in the specialized course on machine
learning
we developed a series of courses for
practical tutorials
that provide the solid foundation for
students on this important topic
that are often uh you know misunderstood
because of this
boom and all so to so topics that we
review in this courses includes data
preparation data mining
classification model training validation
and many others
so in this course series uh you will
learn about
computational innovation and algorithmic
improv
improvements that are quite that have
been quite important for this biomedical
uh data discovery
uh um that we are seeing
so as elia told you all these courses
that we discussed
are now bundled under a single uh basic
subscription
and which is available only for ten
dollars a month or
a monthly subscription and to subscribe
and start
this uh start your bioinformatics ngs
data
research please use this
link feature if you can if you could
share the link for
a registration for the basic
subscription and
with this information i will pass it on
to ilya to take this forward
thank you everyone
thank you muhit and thank you everyone
for joining us today
i did want to mention that we have
a number of options to
get started for free and so i do hope
that most of you that are here today
with us
will be able to get started for free
give us feedback
and try out some of these resources both
on the edu
portal you can try for free on the
code omix logic playground you can also
get started for free
we're very interested in your feedback
so please do let us know what you might
have in mind for how you can use this uh
in your either education in your studies
or in your training as a faculty member
and we do have our team here with us
which
includes uh support at pine bio
for any questions any technical
questions that you might across
that you might find on the platform in
the coding
or the courses and as well as uh
any kind of uh marketing questions if
you have any questions about
registration
any question about the different
programs you can contact marketing
at pi dot bio uh so if you could please
put in that contact information here
thank you
um and if you're interested in
developing resources
for your um own training
i will be happy to interact with you
personally
my email is ilia pine.bio and i'm
looking forward to
to discussing the options for that
now those of you that would like to
receive a recording of this webinar
and see some of the other methods and uh
resources that we have uh please visit
our youtube channel
uh please uh beeps if you could uh paste
the link to our youtube channel as well
and obviously we will follow up by email
to share with you
the recording of this webinar and some
instructions
on how to get started that we covered in
this session
thank you again for joining and looking
forward to
continuing to see more engagement
in these different courses that we
discussed today
and we will have another webinar very
soon
to continue to talk about how you can
build programs
based on some of these resources that we
have discussed